Uh,
before we entered this studio,
I went through the political service.
And to tell you our,
I exchanged with you and said,
but come and tell me what you're telling me off the air,
on the air,
because there is concern
at the highest peak in the state.
Why is there 1 change in tone?
At the Ministry of the Interior,
we were able to get several,
uh.
Our recent
on the state of farmer mobilization,
you are.
For example,
yesterday,
uh, we've come by,
the mobilization has gone from 3000 farmers
mobilized at 9000
in only 1 afternoon.
It means that the movement has been multiplied by 3,
he tripled.
Uh.
And we are
passed from 2000 agricultural equipment to cinq-mille-deux-cents
at 5pm. So,
at the Ministry of the Interior,
uh, we're relatively,
yes, we're worried,
uh.
Because the instruction has been given since the beginning
not to make any interpellation,
to accompany the movement as much as possible.
But we see it,
policy responses
do not come,
or are not suitable in any case.
But we haven't since yesterday.
Either way,
we have to wait for the European Council on Thursday.
Nothing will happen before Thursday.
Gabriel Attal will speak this afternoon.
Do you think he will propose things?
It will certainly propose things.
Then,
the question is whether they are suitable,
if they satisfy,
uh.
Farmers.
So the intelligence police
territorial fear that the movement will last.
At least 5 more days.
5 days. Uh.
And he's even afraid that at the end of the 5 days,
the movement grows,
with notably
of the French who could try to
join the movement.
So French people who are not,
uh.
Farmers.
So that's what's causing concern.
And may I just finish.